what is going on everybody and welcome
to a bit of an update and exhibition of
this new function calling capability as
well as like some of these other API
updates uh but mostly things are just
faster and cheaper now but the big thing
here is function calling and I think
this is going to be uh a massive change
in programming
just in general but also the kind of
intersection of programming and Ai and
adding sort of intelligence to your
programming so what I want to do is just
show some quick examples of kind of how
I've played with it so far as well as
kind of run through their example I
don't think that their their
documentation is good enough but I think
it leaves a little bit to be uh desired
I suppose uh in thinking about what are
all the things that we really can do
with this because this is unbelievably
powerful so anyways uh with that let me
pull up my example and in this case I'm
just importing open AI we will use I
thought Json at some point down here but
anyway we'll get to that point and then
this this notebook I'll put up on GitHub
so there will be a link in the
description so really I just kind of
want to quickly like run through these
examples you don't have to follow along
or anything like that just know hey this
is this is like a possibility now and uh
this is
thundering and lightning outside
apparently this is really cool uh
ominous isn't uh anyway so here we go so
historically if you wanted to do
something like this like for example uh
if if you had a user and that was just
chatting with gpt4 they might ask you
know hey what's the weather like in
Boston and if you just sent that to the
API via the usual chat completion you'd
get a response like this I'm an AI
language model I can't provide real-time
information blah blah blah blah blah
right and it even suggests where you
could find that which isn't you know
useful but it doesn't actually answer
the question but we as programmers we
could totally have a function on our end
that does pull weather data but to do
that you would need deterministic
information like what's the location and
also did they actually want the weather
data for that location right so uh so in
this case uh imagine you have and this
is the example that openai used and this
is like the only one which is kind of a
bummer because like I said this is so
powerful uh that I think uh we're gonna
see some crazy stuff coming from this
capability but for for now this is the
example so imagine this is your function
and somehow you're getting the weather
data based on some location and this in
this case it's really doing nothing it's
just kind of returning the weather info
for some location but you could imagine
you have a function that gets the
weather information based on some
location and this is something that gbd4
just can't do for you yet because it's
not connected to the internet it can't
pull data it can't scrape data but you
can as a programmer so imagine you've
got this function and you know you if if
the user wants weather data you know you
need the location that they requested
and so you want to be able to pull that
sort of structured data from gbd4 and
historically while this has been
possible with like pre-prompts and kind
of making these sort of like forms it's
been clunky you've had to do a lot of r
d to figure out which which one works
best and all that kind of stuff for us
here uh it just works
um and you can kind of force it to work
as opposed to historically like with
some of the projects I've been working
on sometimes it doesn't work and it's
hard
if not impossible to like force it to
work so anyways to get this to work now
what we have here is a new kind of
completion where first thing to note is
we have a new model uh this is gpd40613
which is like the version number I
suppose uh so you will need to use that
I forget when exactly the old GPD or the
current gpt4 gets deprecated but you do
need this for now eventually you won't
need this little end piece but anyways
so here we still pass the exact same
thing that we did before like oh up to
this point everything's the same just a
slightly different model version but
then we add this new thing which is
functions uh and in here this is where
you describe
the function that you may or may not use
based on a user's input and this one
thing to note does get passed to gpt4 it
will suck up your context so if you uh
have you you don't you could have as
many functions note this is plural so
you could have a lot of functions like
right now this is just one function but
you could have tons of them that are
possible so you can already imagine like
an actual like you know Jarvis like home
assistant you could do all kinds of
stuff you could dim your lights you
could get the weather you could play
music you could play a video you could
order something on Amazon right you
could do anything right you could have
functions for all those things and you
could automatically detect and determine
and extract what exactly it is the user
wants so anyways here you just describe
the function uh that you may or may not
use so in this case it's get current
weather that's the name of the function
it should you for all of this again it
goes into the context
and this version of gpd4 has been
trained to handle this type of input and
context so it's going to be
exceptionally good at this kind of
structure but the more effort you put
into making this be as descriptive and
useful as possible noting that this is
part of the context I think you will
achieve better and better results so we
name it get current weather and that is
also just happens to be the name of the
function it wouldn't have to be but if
uh if gpt4 in this case does detect that
this is the function that should be used
given a user's input it would be
convenient I think if the names do match
equally then it will be very easy for
you to understand oh we want to run this
function
but you don't really have the function
doesn't even need to actually exist and
this is an important an important thing
there doesn't have to be a function and
I'll show an example at the end of there
isn't any function but we're using this
functionality to do cool stuff
now
um so anyway will you describe the
function again this is just this is up
to you to come up with a good
description that will help gpd4 to
determine are we trying to run a
function or is this some other piece of
input because alongside you know playing
music and all these other things you
could also just ask the agent you know
how are you doing today we don't need to
run a function for that we're just going
to answer that so uh anyways we describe
the entire function and then we start
defining these parameters and what what
this new function calling which I think
is a not really an appropriate name but
whatever uh all it's doing is attempting
to generate the parameters that you will
pass to the function that you're
describing here so again it's hard to
kind of wrap your mind around that or at
least it was for me to be like oh this
is all we're doing we're just extracting
structured data period
um and so so now we've got this function
now we're going to Define all of the
parameters that are in here and
basically it's going to be in here
in this case we have one parameter and
that is location so we just need to know
where is this person asking for the
weather and then this just further
defines that location and here you can
start to severely restrict the
possibilities of a location for example
and then here finally you can say it is
required that we have a location but you
could imagine in the future that there
might be some parameters that are that
may be passed but not necessarily
required so it's cool that we can even
do that finally we get to function
called Auto there are three options here
you have function call Auto this means
gpd4 will kind of automatically
determine whether or not you actually
want to run you know this function and
get output as output that is the
parameters to this function or you can
pass none and that will essentially
force it to not use any of your
functions do not you know so if the user
just says hey what's going on or
whatever don't try to pass it through a
function and then you finally can pass a
very specific you can pass like name
equals and the exact function that you
100 do want it to run and this again is
extremely powerful because in the past
even if you supplied a form and you told
it to fill out this form and you tried
to force it to do what you wanted it to
do sometimes it just wouldn't or it
would change the form or it would change
the formatting of the form and then
you'd have to parse it or figure out how
to part it was so annoying whereas this
just forces it to happen I hit some keys
I don't think I changed anything but uh
anyway so so this is how you build the
new completion and this is just this is
just Json so this is just how to
describe a Json object basically so you
can pass anything you want in here so
we'll we'll come to that that fits the
Json description anyways continue on so
I just described all that so then if we
are to run this notice that I did
function call Auto so we're letting it
determine if this function should be run
in this case it does determine that the
function should be run it's a function
call Finish reason
and then we come down here
um the message this is where you would
normally get content but in this case
there is no content part of me wishes
that you could tell gpt4 to also produce
that content I understand we're saving
tokens by not doing that but if anyone
from open AI is watching which I doubt
uh uh it would be nice to be able to say
hey populate content or if there is a
way someone let me know in the comments
down below because you will oftentimes
still want the agent to respond in some
way besides this but anyways nonetheless
we carry on uh and you you still could
because you could still pass a query yet
again and then just say function none
right and get the response it would just
cost you one more query and one more
weight for that query uh anyway
continue on the function call does run
we get the argument for location in
Boston and then it tells us the name of
the function because in this case we
just have the one so it's obvious which
function it was but you could imagine
you could have hundreds of well probably
not hundreds because you'd probably blow
context but you could have a lot you
could have tens probably dozens
um okay so so that's pretty cool so we
get okay the location Boston then
theoretically you pass that through to
your your function that uh grabs weather
for Boston for example
obviously this is hard to read or hard
to use so at least in my tinkering this
is how I converted it there might be
better ways to do it but essentially you
can use this this right here is still an
it's like an open AI Json object but
it's like a specific to open AI so it's
their own custom Json object apparently
but it does have an attribute that we
can or a method that we can convert to
dict and then we're just grabbing that
function call and then argument which is
like literally a function call arguments
uh then from here we're loading it via
the Json module and then we can print it
out and then print a location so in this
case we're printing funks so it's just
location Boston but then if we really
wanted to grab that location Boston now
we're ready to do whatever the heck we
want to do with it
so um not only can we extract
information from a user's input so in
this case everything that gpt4 needed to
populate this so all the structured data
that we wanted gpt4 to extract was
contained in that user's input
but it doesn't have to be so one of the
examples I've shown here
is the previous video I did was term GPT
and the idea was you know hey we used
gpt4 all the time to produce uh you know
python code or commands that we might
run in the terminal what if we just
automated that whole process so I'm
using a relatively decently long
pre-prompt because I I need to do in
that case I do a One-Shot learning
example and then basically have it fill
out you know the rest on its own uh but
then I have to parse that and sometimes
it doesn't follow what I told it to
follow
especially if you're using GPT 3.5 which
by the way you can use all of this that
I'm showing right now I'm using gpd4 but
you can also do it through GPT 3.5 which
is huge because that's way cheaper
faster everything and again the reason I
was not using GPD 3.5 was because it did
not follow my instructions as well as
gpd4 but now I haven't tried with gbd
3.5 but this should work just un like
way better I expected it will I bet we
can do term GPT with 3.5 now I'll
probably end up updating it to do that
but this also completely changes
basically it it nullifies all of the
code up to this point for term GPT
because this replaces it entirely so
imagine you have a prompt that says
um oops well this is my function call so
I guess I'll describe that first but
this is the prompt it's like how do I
install tensorflow for my GPU
so
in this case I want to get all of the
commands to do that and then
theoretically we could run them through
the terminal but what I really want to
extract here is all the terminal
commands now if we just let gbd4 answer
this it will provide a bunch of text and
then it will provide those commands but
then we'd still have to extract them and
it's possible to do this just by seeking
out probably like the the tilde tilty
tilde bash and then tilde tilt utility
in this case but I would get less
wrapped up in in doing that and like
well we could do that without doing this
but really
what instead I'm trying to show is not
only can you extract structured data
from a user's input we can use gbd4 to
respond with extremely perfectly
deterministic structured data so this is
just an example of that so someone asks
how do I install tensorflow on my GPU so
okay fine so the message that we pass is
literally that prompt and then here I
just described it up above but I'll just
describe it down here as well the
function we're calling is get commands
this function doesn't even exist it
doesn't exist but but then I describe
this function as get a list of bash
commands on an Ubuntu machine and in
fact I almost probably would change that
uh
yeah so I changed it up here I think but
I forgot to change it down there but get
a list of bash commands to run on a
Ubuntu something like that might even
make more sense but again this is what I
mean by this is going to be used in the
context so the better you describe this
and kind of uh formulate this the better
your responses are likely to be but
anyways running it this way
we then say the parameters type object
commands the type of so it's the
commands is the parameter name the type
in this case is an array and guess what
an array can be of any length so so here
maybe we're expecting two commands maybe
we're expecting 12 commands doesn't
matter because this is an array so then
the type what's going to be contained in
that array it's going to be a bunch of
strings and then the description of each
little type is a terminal command string
uh and then the description of commands
is a list of terminal commands that are
a list of terminal command strings to be
executed again this is all like my first
run through and then I attempted to kind
of fix it here uh purely because I was
kind of wording this in terms of what I
wanted to be extracted but really the
way that you want to think about this is
as if you have a function even if you
don't have a function as if you had a
function you're describing how that
function works and then here you're
describing what is that parameter and in
this case I'm it's as if I'm still
trying to tell gpd4 hey I want you to
get a list I think that's a that this
will work as you'll see in a moment but
I think you can you can prompt it better
by envisioning it as you are describing
the function that will be passed through
because this is how the model's been
trained so you want to keep this in mind
as you're creating this stuff if you
want to have the best results
now in this case just as an example a
function call is auto so I left it as
Auto now if we run this you can see that
the reply content has nothing to do with
a function call at all instead it just
tells me to install tensorflow you'd
normally follow these steps right that's
not what we want this is not uh
structured in any way for us
so that's what happens when you do auto
but instead we can set it the function
call to say name and then we want to
actually run get commands so this
instructs and informs gpd4 kind of hints
and nudges that no no don't respond to
me as like an agent respond to me with
this function parameters and and doing
that changing nothing else it indeed
responds in that way and I and again as
I go through this I think that I think I
could have probably written this
description better to describe the
function itself not what I wanted it not
what I wanted gbd4 to do describe the
function itself because again that's not
really what it was trained to do but
nonetheless despite my uh failings it
does respond in the correct way it is a
function call it determines that okay
these are the arguments this is for
function get commands and then now we
can go ahead and format it in this way
and now you can see here this is that
exact list of commands so again Not only
was this you you know getting structured
data from an unstructured response that
what would otherwise have been an
unstructured response where we're like
eliciting these exact commands and in
fact if I go back up here I don't I
never even really took a deep look at
this I don't know yeah there's some
there are some like bash but even here
you can see uh this one didn't even use
like that bash moniker so again you're
going to be looking for you know these
cases of double or triple tilde but
sometimes it says bash sometimes it'll
say python all that it'll be very you
just could not you couldn't rely
on that you know it was so tedious
whereas now you can rely I I I can't
quite say it's like going to be 100
accurate but I I think that uh at least
again I didn't even do this right and uh
I still got exactly what I wanted so
it's pretty cool so
um yeah so I can't as I wrote here and I
still just uh it just puts a big old
smile on my face because like this is so
powerful that I just I can't wait to see
what people do with this because this is
just so completely open-ended because
you can do like anything and you can
properly tie in AI into otherwise
deterministic programs which I just
before now that has been very hard and
very finicky and tough very tough to do
uh whereas now it's like no it's totally
possible now
so uh one more example that I want to
show before I'll wrap it up this is
already longer than I expected this to
be
um imagine uh you have the following so
this might be another way that you would
elicit different types of things through
like a form or something like that so
imagine you've got user input the input
could be whatever it wants but then you
want to have various personalities to
your AI maybe you've got a nice one a
Mean One a sarcastic one whatever this
could be as much as you want so in this
case what I've said is I just asked a
simple question is it safe to drink
water from a dehumidifier
um and uh and then we just pass it as
normal again make sure of course you're
using that latest 0613 gbd4
and then again I don't this function
doesn't exist I have in this case
especially I've known like in this one
uh the get commands
um this function would eventually be
written because you would need to you
know os.system or whatever the commands
that it comes up with
in this case
you still would probably have a function
because you're going to pick which
personality but again it just doesn't
have to exist but get varied personality
responses so the description of this
function correctly written is it ingests
the various various personality
responses the parameters that we accept
we have a sassy and sarcastic and then a
happy and helpful but you could put as
many as you wanted in here if you know
whatever you can think of Talks Like a
Pirate whatever
and again so string string
the description of this string is a
sassy and sarcastic version of the
response to a user's query a happy and
helpful
version of the response to a user's
query so you can already see where I'm
going here and then required is both of
them but again we could pass different
variations of all of them also different
variate some of them wouldn't
necessarily be required so when
applicable you could have a sassy and
sarcastic response and then when it just
really doesn't make any sense uh you
wouldn't need that or something like
that so then again we are going to force
the function call and then here we get
you know what's pretty hard to read but
then we can kind of split those apart
and then we can get the sassy and
sarcastic version oh sure if you fancy a
little microbial microbial cocktail go
right ahead but seriously don't
um yes that's exactly what I was after a
sassy and sarcastic response
um very good and then the happy and
helpful uh I'm sorry I don't know if
that's really good for happy and helpful
but it's not recommended to drink water
for me anymore while it's extracting
water from Air dehumidifiers uh don't
filter or a clean water okay so you can
see here that okay we just extracted two
different variations of a response again
this is like
uh you know 0.000
of what can be done with this sort of
capability but really what I wanted to
drive home is it's not just extracting
information from a user's input it's
it's a
it's just creating structured data
whether it's from a user's input or from
what otherwise would have been the
output from gpt4 uh
it's just it's really cool and I can't I
did not see this coming certainly not
this fast
um and this is always this has been a
thing everyone's been doing it such an
obvious thing to create
um I can't believe that they actually
like further train the model to do this
very specific thing
um and I I'm just kind of Blown Away I
didn't see this coming I don't think
that they hinted that they were even
doing this so
um yeah that's just really cool so uh
anyway that's all for now like I said
I'll put a link in the description to uh
this exact uh notebook but as you can
see you can probably come up with your
own but getting the kind of structure
down and just kind of starting to work
with this stuff and kind of getting used
because like I said this my first
attempt was the term GPT thing where I
like I I already made the mistake like
I'm not trying to extract I'm not trying
to tell gpd4 hey produce me this list
I'm actually trying to it already knows
that it needs to do the thing based on
that description of that function so so
anyway just a little stuff like that
it's going to take a little bit to get
used to like this pair dime
um but it's just so cool it's so cool
um so anyways if you guys have any
questions comments concerns whatever you
know the deal feel free to leave them
below uh also if you have like ideas or
or things that you think
um that can be done here that are a
little more than what I've already
brought up feel free to leave those
below because like I said I think
there's going to be a lot of uh I hate
to use the word like hacky stuff but
that's kind of what I mean but not in
like a a bad way uh I think there's
gonna be really cool applications and
like I said I just I can't this is
something that I would have expected to
come from like an open source model I'm
very surprised that they've added this
functionality to to gpt4
um so yeah cool
see you guys in another video